good morning what we did last time for
RNA seek is we looked at basically
processing the data and we just assumed
that processing the data with the
standard pipeline will kind of give us
informative enough of an output now we
can take it to downstream analysis doing
some statistical analysis like
differential gene expression and they
looked at different data mining
techniques and interpretation so today
we want to go a little bit more in depth
and the sections that we will be using
is the section there on top and that
will give us processing data and
differential gene expression as a single
and interface and then over here you can
see the supervised unsupervised analysis
and then visualization and annotation
we'll go through these things but before
we do that just a little bit of an
overview of what we did last time so we
talked about pre-processing steps that
help us eliminate some technical
variability like removing adapters and
PCR duplicates we talked about mapping
and different approaches to mapping
where we can align the reads to do their
relevance genome or the known transcript
so we can just use the GTF file that
contains all the beginning and end
positions of exons and then map all of
our reads only there then we talked
about a combined strategy to do that we
talked about different methods of
quantification and specifically we you
probably saw how our SEM a method that
is used for quantification actually
takes a very long time to run and then
we talked about differential gene
expression and two options that we had
for D SEC 2 and edge now the standard
approach this is a protocol published in
2012 so quite a while back but basically
just an idea there are a lot of
different mapping and alignment
techniques and there's a lot of
different tools to do all of this so a
group of researchers came up with just
kind of like the gold standard
you should take to process the data and
do differential gene expression and it's
called the tuxedo a pipeline or protocol
and so basically we did the same the
same thing last time right so we use top
hat as your mapper that includes in it
already both time and then you have
these cuff links cuff merge cuffdiff
potentially if you want to do
differential gene expression and then
you can modify each one of these steps
so you can use star as your align
alignment or bwa instead of bowtie and
so you can replace the different
sections but the overall idea is the
same and this is what it looked like
last time when we did it so you can see
top hat which today has been replaced by
high set to and then you have cufflinks
cuff lurch and then you take that
information and you align all of your
reads unidentified transcripts and then
you have to prepare an expression table
and that is the step of quantification
now there are other approaches to
alignment and one of the significant
ones that has been introduced
I believe in 2014 is alignment that is
not so a quantification or
identification of genes without the
alignment step and that is an approach
that significantly reduces time and it's
based on a different idea so the idea in
alignment and what we typically do with
both time top-hat is that we know
specific regions and then each read
could be aligned to different segments
with different quality so you have to
kind of try and alignment multiple times
and then evaluate the quality of
alignment and then choose the best one
or choose a certain threshold below
which you don't want to continue
aligning them so that is the
computationally intensive step that
could be replaced by a different
approach that instead of using the reads
and the length of that read it just
breaks everything down into
length of a segment called Kaymer so you
can define what the K would be but it
could be 50 nucleotides 120 times long
whatever it is and then you can separate
all of your reads and all of your gene
positions
into the same length segments and then
find matches and constitutionally that's
a significantly less intensive procedure
so sailfish does that and then you can
also improve your quantification speed
by using a similar approach and here you
have an example of htc count there's the
publication on htc so those two
approaches just important to know that
the quality in the end is going to be
very comparable specifically for genes
and known isoforms in some cases people
report that it's not as accurate for
non-coding RNA so if you don't have poly
a if you have total RNA sequencing and
you're looking for additional
information that is beyond genes and
isoforms you might want to consider not
using these methods but if you're
looking for speed and efficiency this
would be the way to go
now finally we talked about the SEC 2
and H are and they're the main two
considerations are the significance of a
gene that you think or that has been
identified as differentially expressed
and your log full change or full change
house not just whether there is a
significant change but also quantifying
the difference and so to jump to this so
a lot of pipelines are built around this
step the assumption is that you have two
groups of samples and you want to
identify what is the difference between
them not in all cases is that possible
to say I've got these two groups and so
what we want to talk about today is
for this step how do we create a clean
book at our own data and understand what
is signal versus noise and see how
preparation of our data actually impacts
this final step they were all interested
in what is the biological variation that
we're trying to say so here are some
questions that you know we want to
review today how do we evaluate the data
quality Before we jump to conclusions
about what this means what is the
quality or data the second is what do we
consider to be our signal do we actually
take the raw data that we got or do we
have to do some transformation to that
data Before we jump into this analysis
and then also what is the objective of
the study and and that of course is
going to be linked to how can we
interpret and validate our results and
so the first big kind of section I think
that is very important and a lot of
times overlooked is exploratory data
analysis and transformation
normalization of your raw data so as you
remember F began was the measurement
that we use to want to find our reads
and their abundance and specific G and F
began stands for fragments for killed a
spur million which means that we are
taking two assumptions or two data
points beyond just abundance of reads
and that is the total number of reads as
well as the length of a gene so if you
have a very long gene its abundance is
not going to be it is going to be
affecting how many reads could
potentially fall on it right and how
many total means you have also is going
to have to say but it turns out that
just using that data in certain
situations is not going to be enough
normalized for us to do subsequent steps
and the way we can check that is by just
thinking and look at the table of
expression that we got last time now all
of you have this data from either the
pipeline that you ran or in the zip
don't that I said to you but this is
what it looks like you have the gene
genes are you rose the samples are your
columns and you have two groups right so
you really have two conditions that
we're comparing you we have normal light
and cloud and look so typically when you
do an experiment like that you are
assuming that within each group you'll
have reference right so you're really
saying that all of these samples
represent one condition and all in these
samples represent another condition
therefore if you were to map how the
same gene is expressed between these two
samples you're expecting them to be
fairly similar right so if you do that
you are going to expect that all of the
values are going to be distributed along
this line right but but in this case
this is an FP cam data and you can do
this yourself and it looks nothing like
they're correlated right so we're
actually making a wrong assumption here
thinking that they are replicates and
because of that standard step before
going further is to use logarithmic
scale and we'll talk a lot about why
this is important but what you have in
your folder just you know if you want to
follow along and see what that looks
like in the data itself in the folder
you have this file called cell lines
expression genes
okay so this was the original table and
you can see just at the range of numbers
that you have in this table right you
have very small values like 8 and even
0.1 and then you have fairly large ones
in the thousands right so you have 2500
here you have so many different types so
you have a variance of data that you're
dealing with and one of the ways to just
see what we're looking at right is if
you take the same data point and you
transform it into normal logarithm skin
so you can take this plus 1 because you
can't take logarithm of zero so you have
to have something there so you can use 1
and you will get this transform table
and it turns out that using this as
signal is going to improve the quality
of your comparison between these
replicas right so if you look at
original fpkm versus logarithmic scale
you can now see that the values are more
aligned with this line meaning that we
can rely on this data to represent the
group that we have them in but to do a
more in-depth analysis of this you have
to look at a few other parameters it's
not enough to just do logarithmic scale
and assume you know every time this is
going to be exactly correct and there's
a few things that we're going to
discover here about the quality of data
as well as we do some summary statistics
so in Excel and again you don't have to
do this in Excel but because it's a you
know easy to use tool we can do it in
Excel and everybody can add the data
package in excel that allows you
do this you can run descriptive
statistics and you will get a number of
statistical measurements about your
dataset so you will get things like the
mean the standard error median mode etc
so you will get a number of parameters
that you can deal with to summarize your
data and if we visually plot this
information we will actually see that
there is a difference between the two
groups of samples right so as you can
see over here it appears that in normal
like samples the mean is higher you can
also see on this side that the Sun is
higher and the sample variance is higher
and what is important about this is
right now we don't know why right so
what we want to discover is how to
normalize but also why do we see this
difference and whether it represents a
biological biologically meaningful data
point or not here on this side you can
see for those two samples that we
consider as just to go back a little bit
I was just a little bit used about what
exactly we're taking the log full change
of like in the slide you have just one
column where the operation is done so
that's just an example from what I mean
up we're taking the log pull change of
the raw data not the full change delete
this right so this is just exactly what
we're doing is we want to replicate all
of these samples right mmm
and just do log scale of all of the data
points so I want to take this gene and
this value of its expression and I want
to convert it to log scale so what I
would do is they will take normal
logarithm of this plus one and I just do
that because now I can copy and paste it
and not worry about the zeros right and
so I can you know stretch it out and I
will get it for all of the same
each column and then and then when
you're preparing two columns with the
correlation plot they look exactly so
and we can do that right now so let's
this way
okay so now I have the logarithm scale
and just so that we see like that I'm
trying to do here so right so these are
going to be the same samples the same
expression values for the same genes put
it in a difference now if we take these
two and we just say let's do a scatter
plot okay so that is what you were
seeing on the slide and now let's do the
same thing and you say like that right
and a little bit we'll see kind of what
exactly how else can we look at all of
this - to understand other things about
- so now another way to look at the data
is to prepare a histogram and this is
what you're seeing on this side and why
is that important so a histogram says
let's think of bin from 0 to 5 to 74 on
the raw scale and let's take everything
separate them into these bins and just
count how many of the genes do I have
that have this expression and so what
you can see is that you have a lot of
outliers and then most of your data in
the very low heads so why is that bad
that's bad because let's take t-test or
any other kind of statistical test it's
going to have some assumptions about the
distribution and it's going to look for
how the means are different or some kind
of a statistical aspect of the data and
measure that difference and when you
have something that looks like that that
means that these numbers that you are
interested in that are all over here are
going to be underrepresented they're not
as significant because they're you know
on the scale of everything there in the
lower values now let's take a look at
the same descriptive statistics but for
logarithmic scale and so you can see
you know that everything is kind of more
stretched out so if you compare this to
seeing something under the light or
outside of the light right if you are
trying to keep their colors and it's
dark it's not as easy to differentiate
between dark red and dark green right
but if you have bright light then now
you can see what's even you know maybe
define it much better what is the
difference and that is what this really
allows you to do and now you can start
seeing other things that emerge from
this transformation for example right
here you know the mean and the median
and standard air they're about the same
but all the sudden kurtosis is sticking
out right here right so you can see that
for the normal light it's much higher
and this brings us to another point that
is going to be very important about our
data and that is variation you know
distribution of values and that we want
to take a look at and specifically here
what you can notice is that you have
this this thing coming up here and it's
again into low values right so even for
logarithmic scale in your cloud and low
samples you have quite a lot of genes
with low expression and the question is
why you know is this something that is
biologically meaningful that I'm going
to want to pay attention to or is this
something that is not worth my attention
and I don't really want to look at so if
we overlay one sample on the other just
in terms of their histogram what we can
see is that they are different from the
normal distribution and we want to look
at the so the bottom you know if we want
to take a look at differentially
expressed genes a lot of genes are going
to be differentially expressed right so
you have you know these probably I mean
all of these are going to be
differentially expressed
but the question is how believable is it
that they actually are and because
there's such low values it's actually
indistinguishable from noise so you
cannot rely on them just randomly doing
different sequencing techniques you know
different machines you will get a lot of
this variation so that is not where you
want to pay attention to then you have
this hump in the middle and those are
going to be representative of normal
gene expression so if you take any two
living cells they have to function in a
certain way so you have a lot of genes
that are responsible for that
functionality and they're going to be
present even in cancerous cells or other
types of cells so you don't want to I
mean they're going to be informative of
course but they're not going to be as
informative but then here you actually
have a very significant signal and that
is the signal that we want to look at so
if we want to focus on the signal then
we need to separate somehow between the
signal and the noise and the way to do
this is to draw a line between these two
and what we've seen and a lot of
publications that have been looking at
different gene expression data using
alumina sequencers is that it's going to
be right around 5:00 on explore ethnic
scale so if you take your gene
expression you transform it to
logarithmic scale everything below that
threshold of 5 is going to be very noisy
everything above that logarithmic scale
of 5 is going to be of interest and what
are the methods that you can use to
separate the signal from the noise is to
use quantile normalization so let's do
that together what we will use is this
file right here cell lines filter 6 and
we can go to the platform and just
quickly do this together
bigger and I hope that everybody's got a
the account information with you if you
don't I have a test account so
everybody's got their account
information okay so what we want to do
is go down here under utilities and
upload this file that we have you'll go
under cell lines and then you have the
cell lines filter six to look something
like that
you have your gene IDs and the sample
ideas and nothing else continued and
here you've got 20 normalization so what
does quantile normalization do quantum
normalization takes these differences
and aligns them by aligning the mean and
then normalizing everything to go from
the so if you if your mean is 5 in this
you know group of samples and in this
group of samples it's 10 they're gonna
both end up being the same number and
then everything will stay the same but
from that and I think if you read
through this down here there's a link
that you can read more about this but
here you also have the option to already
transform this to logarithmic scale so
you don't have to do this in Excel or
make you look as you can just go ahead
and press yes and here you can sub
threshold 5 now what will happen if you
don't do a threshold it will be exactly
the same so if you don't do any
threshold then your output file is still
going to contain some variability inside
but much less and if you do the threat
of 5 it's gonna actually leave
everything about fives
to be more comparable so
you want to focus on that signal and you
can also do PCA but in our case well
actually let's go ahead and just do that
you also have some filtering abilities
right here so if you want to go ahead
and set up a filter you have two options
you can do a fixed number like filter
everything below a certain threshold
which were already doing on top of
organization or you can just take only
the 25% right so what is interesting a
lot of times when you do PCA is you want
to focus on the variability that is most
representative of the differences
between the samples samples that you
have so you can also do that in our case
we have to do that let's just save and
save it now today we are going to look
at another and another project that I
wanted talking about if if you take a
long time and get stuck so just go ahead
and click on one high point the other
project that I have here is a project
also about breast cancer and there you
can see a lot more of the impact of
wanton normalization on the end result
so I also prepared this data set that we
can take a look at together so let's
prepare another pipeline for for this
bottle right here which is the exact
same thing it's just expression values
for all the samples so we can click here
create utilities in the house pipeline
and we can go into the DCMS it's called
backdoor carcinoma
and you can take a look though this is
the file one down mobilization trance
one to water in the scale five okay so
what is this going to give us to look at
how we can interpret this data instead
of going through all the steps of
summary statistics and looking at
individual parameters that we have been
reviewing up until now a useful way to
kind of summarize your data is to use
box plots and so box plots just to
understand what we're looking at they
summarize the data in a visual way that
is easy to kind of get a feel for as you
look at all of your samples so it will
plot all of your conditions or all of
your samples or groups of samples if you
want to and then provide you with a
minimum and the maximum value the median
value and you could also have the mean
value to here and then your inter pond
interquartile range so there the range
between 25 and 75 is going to be in your
box or you can look at the whole range
and they will also a lot of times plot
outliers so you can take a look at what
that looks like so if we do this and
I'll show you here in a second how to do
that in Excel if you would like to but
basically this is what it looks like for
raw data for the FBI and data so the
same idea right all we see is basically
the outliers and all of our main values
are down at the lower end of the scale
and if you do logarithmic scale you kind
of stretch everything
right so what will happen after portal
normalization let's take a look so let's
go back to our table we don't though
this was for how correlated they are
right and now what we can do is we can
just select all of this and again in
Excel you also have this function so you
can just do a box-and-whisker and it
will show you what we were just seeing
there right so everything is down at the
bottom let's take a look at the
logarithmic scale
okay so now you can see a lot more in
this chart and again you kind of see
also the X is the mean the line is the
median when you can see here by just
focusing on that for example is that the
mean and the median are not aligned for
the normal like that they are aligned or
crowded low which is actually interested
so now let's take a look at our
pipelines so that we can get the
quartile normalized data so my pipeline
finished here and then you have this all
want down normalization download
actually it's also here take that and
let's open that in Excel and we can just
copy it over to this spreadsheet right
here
so what will happen to these
so as you remember we didn't have to do
the logarithmic scale and Excel was just
kind of did it within the organization
itself what you can see is that you know
we gave it a threshold so it's not
perfectly aligned but it's much more
aligned between them and it's got as
someone to logarithmic scale right but
but not exactly so if we take a look at
how these top ends are aligned right
they're not aligned here at all
and here they are aligned right at the
bottom you have a lot more outliers so
it really adds an additional layer of
alignment between these and so we can
start looking at them as more
representative replicas so let's go
ahead and look at what we were doing
before so this was 720 180 634
okay so this is what you get and you can
also eliminate the threshold if you want
and see what will happen if you just
align it
no leaks I just have the names yeah well
why don't you look over here one second
so if you go to the EU site and go to
the organization page I pasted the
download link right here and that's if
you posted earlier
then anyone else
did you get them there yeah so we're
working on sell one second yeah and
everybody else goes the files okay so
what we were doing is we were you know
just doing quantile normalization and
looking at the impact and so right now
we know that our data is normalized and
it's ready for analysis but what we can
oftentimes see is that this
transformation can sometimes not impact
PCA at all
it can change it visit visually as you
can see the difference here this is raw
versus normalized but there's not a lot
of significance to our ability to
interpret right so sometimes you just
see and okay the numbers kind of switch
their positions but it's basically the
same thing right there is not a lot of
difference
maybe it's wider between them but what
it will change is the number of
statistically significant differentiy
Jenks so you can see that this is the
raw the logarithm scale the quantum
normalized so depending on your
threshold what you might consider as
differentially expressed genes and the
raw scale will actually not be
statistically significant enough if you
go and you normalize your data so now
the interesting part the part about why
this might be so what you can see here
is in addition to the tables of
expression you also get mapping
statistics on how many reads were
aligned during the mapping process and
you can see here the difference between
normal like right so the rate of
alignment for normal length and the rate
of our environment for cloud and low is
actually different which means that the
number of reads that were aligned to the
genome
or the transcriptome in your case is
different and what that could mean is
that this is just a representation of
you know contamination different hands
different machines used to actually do
the sequencing so this is really
technical noise that is influencing our
analysis now let's take a look at the
DCIS data we ran this pipeline so let me
download it so we did point out
normalization so let's download that
data right here and let me tell you
briefly about this data set this is a
number of samples between actual normal
healthy tissues which is a little bit
different from the cell lines that we
were dealing with that are not even the
normal like are actually cancer cell
lines but there I'm just not specific to
any subtype and DCIS OBCs
is an early stage cancer that for some
reason for some patients they end up
developing aggressive cancers and some
patients don't so one of the major
challenges with DCIS is trying to
differentiate between those two how can
you know whether a patient with DCIS
with a tumor will end up having an
aggressive cancer and which patient is
not and so when you can see here is it's
imitated here on top for each one of
your samples you have normal right and
then you have different classifications
like paying 50 we talked about it last
time but basically all of those are ECAs
so they have not really become late
stage to reserve this point so if we
take this data right this is the
normalized data what we can see was just
quickly if you here
box-boy
[Music]
lotta computationally that is fantastic
okay there we go
so these are all of our samples after
small motivation and what I want to do
is I want to see the impact of this
mobilization on PCF so and I'll explain
a little more what is that you see it
does again as a review so here you can
see all of our sample is fairly
comparable right so you can't really
tell a big difference even though you do
see a little bit more and a little bit
higher outliers on the side so this data
and now let's quickly try and before I
go into kind of like how to interpret
this let's just prepare a couple of
pipelines here with this data set let's
go to unsupervised analysis and upload
both de-normalized
and the not normalized data for DC areas
so we can take this one which was the
original data and we can run BCA who can
do the are line break and I'll explain a
little bit of what we're doing here
exactly so this is going to be PCA of
raw DC is Theta and then we will do the
same thing with the normalized
Oh
so what I want to demonstrate here is
that actually sometimes these steps that
are linked to eliminating this technical
variability will play a role in our
ability to detect some variance in our
datasets so to quickly explain that I
mean with you I think we did this last
time but just to refresh everybody's
memory what is PCA PCA is a good way for
me to see all of my data in a snapshot
just to understand what the sample
variation is based on all of my cheese
right so here's how it works
if we just have gene 1 and gene 2 for
all of our samples we can select those
genes right and then we can build a
scatter plot so the scatter plot will
show us sample and the X will be gene
one and the Y will be gene - right so
it's just a simple chart of what we have
in the data but we have a lot more genes
right so we can add the third team and
we'll we'll have a three dimensional
plot but how do we get all of our genes
into this scatter plot that's the
question so the dimensions or the
features over here on the side the genes
need to all be represented into
something that is visually interpretive
or for us so the way to do this is to
try to create a new set of dimensions
based on variance in our data and those
are going to be principally or don't
going to be called principal components
so if we have low variance is not
interesting to us if we have high
variance we want to focus on the high
variance and then within that hiya
millions we want to project new vectors
and then project everything onto those
two or number of three components and so
as a result we get pc1 & pc2 as our x
and y and now we can project everything
onto those new components
it gives us the location of each sample
within the space of variance of our
whole dataset okay so it just takes
instead of looking I mean the classic
example is if you look at a pen this way
right I can't really tell a lot about it
if I look at it this way
now I understand kind of some features
about my dataset so that's the same
thing that we're doing here we're
twisting everything in a
multi-dimensional space to find the best
way to represent the variance of data so
now let's see at the result of our
pipelines and how normalization changed
the picture when we did this
transformation with point optimization
so here I have my pca of raw DCIS and I
can take a look at the plots for example
again when you can see here is you have
some outliers right here right and then
the rest of your data is down here
so let's say I don't know which is
normal and which is DCIS I can assume
that maybe some of them over there are
normal and the rest are DCIS but I don't
really have a way to to check that right
so I mean this if I go back and check my
annotation I will actually discover that
this is not normal so if I open this
just so I have a little more control
over the plot I can take at the table
and again do this manually just so that
I understand the position of my samples
so it's open it here and I'll close this
box
so what I have here is my principal
components those projections in the
space that describes my samples and this
one right these two could be chosen to
represent my dataset so I can see that
some of them are right here right the
rest are down here so now I can mark
them right so actually here we have the
annotation within the name of our
samples that you can see that all of
these are normal so let me just insert
some groups here so these are all of my
normal and these would be all DCIS right
and now if I use that information in my
in my chart these would be the normal
ones so I would take just the X or the
normal Y for the normal and that do the
same thing for these yes
and let's see what happens so what
happens is that actually I have a split
in my DCIS so I mean just out here the
legend so you can see that bigger okay
so the normal ones are actually right
here and this is some kind of a split
between VCAs so it doesn't show me in
the variance in my data the biggest
variance isn't between normal and cancer
it's actually within the cancer it is
and that shouldn't happen like just
biologically speaking that's not what I
expected to see and so what it means is
that there is some variability in the
data that can confuse me if I don't have
the annotation the clinical annotation
of what the sample is just by looking at
the data I will come to wrong
conclusions and so you can now see let's
go back to the normalize data and by the
way I don't want to be just doing this
myself I mean I'm hoping that some of
you are able to follow along and so if
you're not maybe let's trying to address
that it's very fast though so yeah so
let's take a pause and make sure that
everybody can follow along so did any
than anyone succeed at creating the
normalization pipeline yeah yes so if
you you have so you have it yes when I
try to pull up on the tower website
there's some issue where it won't let
you scroll down to actually do pca yeah
yeah sure
just yeah Danny buddy I also have this
problem one of the second one will be 20
to find the DC is the one that says no
no the third one third one in the folder
so in the DC is there's this one it's
called the pure jin-haeng whatever GE f
began filtered ended right so all that
was done to this is it was processed
it's an FB cam and the sample names are
annotated that's yeah yeah that's
looking index files so that third one
well yeah go back to the platform to
serve them so the same thing
did you figure out yours yeah yeah I
just took the results from the horn town
normalization and I opened it in the
same Excel files so so just to kind of
review you all have this to the txt
right so this txt you just open it in
Excel so this is the same txt file but
in Excel right now what I did previously
was I manually demonstrated how to
transform this to logarithmic scale but
quantile normalization all already does
that for you but what you can do is if
pipeline finished if you go to the
normalization so this was for ECA get
this yes QM here you have the normalized
pile right here so if you just download
this file did you run this pipeline
running so just reload the page and it
will be I mean shouldn't take long oh
yeah yeah you can't change the password
the password was emailed to you some
time ago but I'll give you inside here
you have this file called server GPIO
access if you don't have access this is
a test account that you can use during
this session so these are the details
that you can use for logging in the test
and I are taken and that's the password
so it was like a conceptual question
yeah like dealing with the slides I
guess so when we know in pca you know
you're starting to do to your first
we're plotting the gene expression
correlation and then like we look at the
it's not your relation these are samples
now the dots are all genes they're
sandwich well at first if they're genes
right I'm gonna go right right rule this
is a sample level of each gene right and
then we can look at that for all genes
together flawed well we can't do it for
all of them we can only do it for like
sum of three because I think I mentioned
so I guess what I'm asking is when we
finally get this this number that we're
gonna plot on our PCA plots yeah yeah
that's like an average of the variance
of all the genes from so it takes all of
your samples for all of your genes sorry
and it tries to find the variants
associated with the whole dataset not
for each individual sample with the
whole dataset and do a projection in the
small T dimensional space that we can't
see but PCA can and do like a projection
which is a vector of numbers and then
take that vector and say this is now
your x and y coordinates pc1 & pc2 or
pc2 and pc3
we can actually see the coordinate so
what is it that we're seeing in the PCA
result
over here this number is it's impossible
to interpret an ingenious present values
it's just something that tells us
something about the variance between all
the samples right so it's unique to the
data set that we're studying but it's
not really interpreting it back into
gene expression knowledge there is a way
to do that which we go through and
transcriptomics to where you can use
these projections and do reverse
projection and actually interpret how
can genes that are responsible for this
sample being way out here how do I find
those you've read it you can't do that
but it's not this number to be able to
expect for that sample it's gonna have
more significantly different genes which
one's right well you have to go look
into that right so now if I did you know
let me take this group and this group
and do differential gene expression you
can find the genes that are responsible
for this separation but it just kind of
gives you an insight visually what can
these numbers all of this gene
expression tell me about this group of
samples I'm studying or exclude maybe
some samples like these in this yeah far
quadrant exactly yep
you can have to go back to areas of
analysis yeah you go under utilities
upload your data the txt file did you
have something yeah so in the utilities
based PCA analysis there's a parameter
for transforming our table to
logarithmic scale yeah you do quartile
analysis and you do a logarithmic
transformation there you should turn off
that option okay yeah you shouldn't do
it but let's take a look at the results
did everybody yes through this stage so
once you dislike normalize that's he now
well now we want to compare pca of
normalize data versus pca of raw data
and see what different conclusions will
we get if we do normalization today
we're good yeah what was that visa all
right what's up the one we have we have
is all right that raw data yeah this one
is rotted really work for you point out
normalization hit a work for you
okay so now if your pipeline has already
finished right and you downloaded the
results so I'll just go there by
pipelines and then I have PCAs
normalized pca they called it and let's
just download the table right away so
opening it in Excel and now I can do the
same thing right so instead of jumping
to the plot let me just insert here what
it is so these are the normal and these
are yes and I just want to do this for
myself to test whether what I will see
will be different
so this is going to be normal and when I
do is I take the PC one as X's and PC -
as Y and now I'm going to add the DC
area so now I actually see what I am
expecting to see right let's just add
the legend here so again the normal are
the bloom here did everybody get the
same thing
so biologically speaking it's much more
reasonable to expect the normal tissue
to be different from the cancer tissue
in a more significant way than to have
some one portion of the DCA s to be more
different than everything else and so I
think that this is a good example of how
working with your data with transforming
it to logarithmic scale filtering for
the noisy part and then using methods
like quantum normalization can help you
get more biologically interpretive or
results it's just you mentioned before
people if we tread on the data or we
don't like the data or we need to go
data the B says who knows so much well
the normal the difference between normal
and DCIS should be more significant than
the difference between one group of DCs
and another group of GCS like we saw in
the previous one right so just to kind
of compare them side-by-side if we take
this and I'll just write here that this
is PCA of one town normalized data let's
take this back over here so the previous
example of raw data
right if we didn't know that this is
normal and this is the rest let's say we
were just examining a group of samples
and you don't know anything about them
well you would naturally focus on is the
difference between those and the rest
right but now that you transformed it
you would naturally go to that kind of
difference which is the more correct
wave right so what I'm trying to
demonstrate is that you know you're
typically not starting knowing already
while you're looking for right you're
just do sequencing in their library let
me now mine my data and see what's in it
and you could be confused if you don't
have your data prepared for your
analysis and going in a completely wrong
direction then everybody get to this
point
all right open water play both fight in
the same well this one is the same I
just copied the chart from the other one
to the PC a result I got for my in that
process gives me this right but it's the
same thing because these values are also
in their parenthesis when it's the same
I mean you know you see it says right
there normal and then there's some types
of what I did is I added a column if you
just add another column and just I
manually typed it in or you could do
these so normal that everything is
normal is this yes it's just that you
have Pam fifty classifications you can
play around and now
now you remember a Terrigen
transformation to logarithmic scales yes
and the threshold was okay so now that
we prepare our data what can we do with
it one of the things that we talked
about is PCA and we can just explore our
data but it doesn't actually give us too
much information beyond visually seeing
some major trends in the data right it
doesn't give us a lot of detail another
method that we talked about what's
clustering now the difference between
the PCA and clustering is that you can
actually assign a number of groups for
example let's say I am expecting to see
three major groups in my data I can use
and you see an expected number of
clusters do three or four or whatever
you feel like and see what will happen
so again it's an unsupervised analysis
in the sense that I'm not telling the
clustering what each class is what the
groups are I'm just kind of giving it a
number and seeing what comes out so
let's try and do that
okay so now what we will do is go back
to areas of analysis and there's a
reason why they're separate
into two major groups right there's an
unsupervised section right here and then
there is a supervisor we'll talk about
both of these today but let's first go
to unsupervised analysis and we can use
the same normalized results that we have
so for example the one for the GC is
data set and we can select hierarchical
clustering and in a little bit I'll
explain what exactly it does you can
also read about it right here you have
several parameters you have linkage
which is how these samples are going to
be linked into clusters so for example
you can use more d2 is a good method for
this type of data you also have
different ways to measure differences
between the clusters because they have
to separate into well-defined groups so
we can keep it at Euclidean and the
numbers of clusters I will expect three
now it does have this option here to
transpose or not transpose now
transposing a table means that you've
got your rows and you can flip them to
the side and now your rows become
columns or your columns become rows and
what is it our rows and columns our
columns are sample names right and our
rows are genes so we can cluster either
our genes based on samples or we can
cluster our samples based on genes so
this is the option so in this case we do
need to transpose because we want to
look at the difference between our
samples and not the genes and just click
on end
this is hierarchical
the other dataset let's just do this
again that we have is the cell lights
and there it's a lot more classes right
so I mean here we really have two or
maybe three but then we have a bunch so
here we can go back to the folder that I
gave you the cell lines and you can
again take well we can take this one
actually before we do know yeah we can
we can use that just that later on we'll
have to update let's take a look at what
happens
so hierarchical clustering 42 so here we
actually do expect five clusters because
we have normal light cloud and lower
luminal basal and I think we have two
types of luminal that were expecting so
and do transpose truth Dave
okay now what is hierarchical cluster
here what a hierarchical clustering does
is again imagine this is our PCA or
whatever projection of samples so each
dot represents a sample it is called the
bottom-up approach to clustering so it
really starts from identifying two
points that have closest to each other
in this multi-dimensional space use a
specific distance measurement and says
which ones are closest if they are
closest then it links them together so
now this round circle around the two
dots is considered to be a single point
in the space and then it identifies the
next two closest points and then more
closest points and it starts linking all
of these points together until we get to
a single cluster like this and the
result is all of this information is
kept so as a result what we can do is we
can build a dendrogram of all of our
samples so this is the result from the
cell lines you've got cell line name
over here for sample names and then all
of these lines represent what I just
showed with the circles right if they
were circled together that's a lie they
were linked together how do we know how
many clusters are in this dataset
well we decide it's a threshold that we
give so this would be two clusters it
would just cut it off right there
this would be four clusters if we cut it
off right there or this would be eight
clusters of concurrent offs right there
so basically the height is a measurement
that we can use to put a threshold and
the result would either be visual like
this or it will be the cluster number
assigned to specific segments so let's
take a look at the result of the
pipeline
so first of all you have this PDF which
is going to be the dendrogram
and this is the DCIS dataset right so a
different dataset now what do we see
here we see here a normal cluster right
here right because this is all
normalized and then we can say well
again we just see all the rest right
here right but in reality within all the
rest there's at least a number of other
significant subclusters and so if I
forget about the number of clusters I
told it that I expected I can use this
to also try and understand what should I
be expecting and that's why this
particular method of clustering is
useful as an exploration tool yeah
- and of different compared to the
viewers maybe you didn't use the
normalized did use the normalize data or
which is a good example right so now can
you give me the so what you see here is
the result from normalized and he ran or
what is again 3e8
right here at the top seven equal three
so if I just changes I will see his
results and this is the results from
non-normalized so you can see that the
normal are still clustered together but
they're kind of in the middle right
now of course we know that this is no
ammos is cheating but it's just to give
us an insight into how you know these
different methods are affecting what we
can interpret so you can see that in the
unnormalized there is some group right
here which seems to be luminal and be
grouped together right but then you've
got all of this stuff over here so it's
really unclear what it is but here you
can see and you can kind of read into
you know what might be the reasoning
behind them clustered together right so
these are all luminal be together these
are maybe they're all white you know or
some other parameter that you can try to
interpret but right now what we're
interested in in the context of using
this is just to explore our data right
let's now consider that we have explored
our data so is everything clear about
kind of what's the usefulness of these
methods okay so we talked about
dendrogram and how we can kind of do it
now let's talk about let's say we know
we've studied a group of samples we kind
of understand pretty well what they are
and what they do and we have a new
dataset and that problem is called the
classification problem so instead of
using the information about how they are
different I can just train a machine and
not knowing what it does it will then
start telling me what it thinks a new
sample is so I can create a training
data set and I label it for the machine
and I tell it this is DCI yes this is
not the CIS or somehow more complicated
for example in our cell line data I have
four or five different types I can make
a data set that has good representation
of those types give it a new training
test dataset and it will tell me what it
is so what are some of the methods that
do that and what are some of the ideas
behind this the simplest idea is a
binary decision
what is the binary decision tree what it
does is it looks at a simple threshold
that can explain the differences in the
data in the same way that we were
looking at the PCA
where we can just take expression of a
gene and say does this gene show us
enough information about the differences
between our samples that I could just
set a threshold for example so what you
can see here is X less than zero point
twenty one or twenty nine that is a gene
so in there a specific threshold of
expression now I can say that lower then
or higher then you can separate all of
our values and four cell lines there are
two genes that actually do that very
well trim three and kam then actually
the first one separates everything from
luminal and the second one separates the
other ones in between themselves so
basically it takes and separates
everything in two types classes now and
we'll do this in a second and we're
actually you know let's run some of this
so that we don't spend time eating so
let's go into areas of analysis under
supervised analysis this time and we can
upload under cell lines we have
supervised 7,000 genes we can start from
this and we have test and train will
first just upload them as is and then
I'll show you what is inside those files
and how to prepare them yourself now you
do have to specify you don't always have
to name them to test and train but you
have to specify which one is trained in
different
so the test will go under testicles
training train and now we can do a
decision tree right here
and while we're here let's go ahead and
do the same thing for the 15 genius but
instead of 7,000 genes you have another
folder here that's called 15 genes again
both files and we can do the trunk yeah
test here
now the problem with this dataset if I
go back to differential gene expression
is that I have more than two groups
right so if I wanted to achieve the same
result with differential gene expression
or some statistical test that would have
to do multiple comparisons between each
other or Laura
Nova or something like that and this
also gives me
unfortunately the limitation of decision
tree is that I will try to minimize how
many genes it actually relies on to
separate between these classes so the
way to overcome that is random forests
and two random forests is a very popular
technique for classification that relies
on the idea of decision trees but it's
kind of is the smart implementation of
decision trees because what it does is
two things
it's bagging so it takes different
portions of the data set not different
portions of samples but different
portions of genes of features and it
tries to run decision tree multiple
times on that portion so randomly
selects portions you know as thing these
ten genes these fifty genes these
hundred genes and run decision tree and
then it can evaluate the results in
terms of accuracy of prediction because
you know what your end result should be
right you know what the test or the
train data set contains and in terms of
its stability
what is accuracy well if you imagine
firstly I don't have that picture here
but if you imagine a circle right and
you're trying to use decision tree to
cut it out from the rest what you will
have
a jagged-edged right that could be kind
of rough so it doesn't give you a very
good precision if you take small
portions along the line of that circle
you can separate it into smaller cutting
you know points and therefore you can
get more precision the second one is
stability and stability refers to some G
team consistently some feature
consistently coming up as significant
for their separation so if it
consistently comes up that means it's
more stable from our prediction and then
class with maximum votes gets assigned
to the sample ok so let's take a look at
the result just with decision treatment
so let's take moved up to 7,000 genes
have to download the zip file of all of
your results and inside you have a plot
that looks similar to what I was showing
you before right so you have two genes
that explain almost all the variation
inside of your dataset and now you can
for example take a look at what is this
gene
okaythat's hpx and then you can take a
little bit what does this Jean but right
but the rules are fairly easy to
interpret so this Jean above a certain
will be luminal below a certain number
will be other kinds right above this so
it's actually telling you how is doing
this kind of stuff
now let's take a look at the other
result for the 15 genes
and this shows you really the problem of
decision tree the problem is that it
will always find something most of the
time it will find something I mean
obviously if it can't be separated it's
not going to find anything but if you
fear something it's going to come up
with a result that best represents the
difference between the classes so the
input is going to be very significant
right so random forest actually
overcomes this problem because it does
the same thing many times so if we give
it less amount of genes it will come up
with a different number of genes and
give it other ones it will come up with
other ones but a random forest will
figure out which ones are the most
stable and the most contributing to
actors so let's run random forest and
we'll take a look at the output so again
we can upload the same let's do seven
thousand genes it doesn't make sense to
do fifteen
now we have a lot of options here for
random forests there's a couple
different options but a parameter that
you can change is the number of trees
that it will London will just take
longer if you have more one faster if
you have less and of course more
reliable if you do more now what you can
do also as you can see there's a random
forest multi-run so as you can see the
repetition of the same thing multiple
times will increase your accuracy and
your reliability of the results and so
doing this more time and you can force
this platform to do it for you and
combine different methods together but
doing it more times will give you more
precise and more reliable so let's just
look at our pipelines and remotely to
people normally like a thousand
iterations or something you can do
whatever I mean there's a lot of paper
it depends on how many classes you have
depends on how many features you've got
a lot of things play around
so as we're waiting let me just tell you
quickly how to prepare the input files
so I actually have to prepare it for the
DCIS right so in BC is what we saw is
that they're two classes maybe three
classes right so I will prefer to say
there's three classes because actually
the paper the paper that published this
theta said that was their conclusion
that they identified one class of DCIS
patients that was more prone to become
to develop these more aggressive tumors
and some class that wasn't so that would
be our interest how can we separate them
so if I go back to my dendrogram
and by the way you can see how this kind
of resembles the pentagram as well that
would be interesting for future
discussion so if I look at this this is
the normalized I can see that within the
normalized right so you remember the
group of samples that was kind of off to
the to the side that right here right so
you can see that you kind of have okay
these guys right here so they were off
to the side and if you see over here I
kind of have you know this separation
with this group and then it happened
within it another separation of this
room so what I can really do is maybe
separate it into this group and this
group and now based on just my
understanding of the data that I got
from clustering I will prepare a train
and infest data set so that I can create
a machine that will tell me why so I can
go back to my original data set and you
have this let's take the normalized one
that I prepared so this would be right
here and we can open that back up in
Excel
and that was what I want to do is like
it depends on what I want to do right I
can either want to know why the
separation happens or I actually want to
test whether my machine will work
accurately on a new data set so cross
validation so in my case I want to know
why so what I will do is I will take the
names of the columns which are my
samples and I can just paste them here
and transpose them so that I get them as
names of rows and as you can see my
labeling here at the end is very simple
right I have normal basil whatever but I
want to now take a look at my death of
Graham and label it according to what I
ate it there you just kind of
arbitrarily pick those separations I
mean not completely arbitrarily but it's
I'm just wondering why I didn't pick
those for that custard separately I can
it just makes more sense to me with the
way the clusters are okay so I've got
the normal so I can keep those as normal
and then I've got these four which is
easier which is a good thing so three
six one so she's right here so I'll call
it V J is one and three six two six
three and five nine
thanks for yourselves from shakes here
thinks maybe shouldn't okay so this is
my VCS one and now I can just but sort
this
and all the rest is going to be easy is
to so now what I want to do is I want to
first of all go back and sort this how
it was and then I want to take this
column go in here
deserted row first
now I'll call this class em and just
transpose okay so now I've annotated
these and created a training data set
that will tell the Machine what I'm
looking for so let's go ahead and save
this and I will save it as I will save
it as a train as a txt file just
remember that it needs to be txt okay so
I will just call it this long train and
what I can't do is just delete this
actually I do have that file and just
for myself so I remember I'm going to
keep it as test
all right so now let's create our
pipeline so it'll take my esta train is
my training there and let's create
random forest
as this is running let's take a look at
the results from the 7000 chip right so
everybody got that pipeline finished the
random forest point trying to scroll
back inside go to download pipeline
files and then I can have bring the
forest all results is what I will pick
and open that zip file and let's see
what it has inside so first of all it is
going to give me prediction for the
classes right so I gave it in my
training set for this dataset I
separated them so that actually not all
the same files not all the same samples
are in both tables so I want to know
here whether it did an accurate job so
this prediction right here is the
predicted class from the training
dataset on a data set that random forest
did not know anything about right so if
we go back and check we will actually
see that it did a pretty good job did
perfectly what we told it to do but it
also gave us as a result here the
feature importance and that is really
what we are interested in the feature
importance is going to be genes that
have a large mean decrease in accuracy
so eliminating that gene from the
dataset will actually cause the accuracy
of prediction to decrease a lot and now
I have a list of my 15 genes which is
how we got the other days so this is
just a way to select those genes that
are going to be most informative for the
classification now if I do this many
times this list can improve in its
quality now 15 genes is not good enough
probably right for Biological
interpretation I have you know tens of
thousands of genes to start from and I
want to go to some pathway annotation
and
Charlie has maybe 15 to 100 genes in it
what am I going to do with 15 genes not
going to be enough for me to accurately
to accurately identify some pathway or
some biological process so I want to
enrich this list so what I can do is now
go back to using clustering to create a
data set from these genes that are all
going to be clustered similar to the
genes that I've selected using random
forests so now I can go back and take my
original expression table plug in only
the 15 genes that I have right there and
consider different methods for
clustering that are now going to be
looking at the same variability but
based on the genes and not the sample so
don't the transpose okay and there I
just have to tell you this is beyond the
scope of this workshop but there when
you deal with expression values and
separation between genes you probably
want to use a different measurement of
distance based on density and so we have
a few methods here that do density based
clustering instead of Euclidean distance
so that is the way that you can use
these different methods and just don't
have a lot of time so I'm going to skip
over a few things so that is how you can
use a combination of supervised or
unsupervised and supervised methods to
first understand your data then do some
analysis that will give you a number of
genes that you're looking for and then
transform that into a data set that you
can take into downstream interpretations
now let's take a look at the result of
our name is pipe length and by the way
here if you want to get a visual you can
go over here and go into random forests
and you
yeah so actually this didn't work let's
go back and this typically happens
because the data set isn't prepared
correctly and by correctly what I mean
is the names and the links of different
columns and rows so probably where I
need to do is I need to simplify this
naming so I'll just do that really
quickly because this is what you need to
pay attention to what you're doing this
kind of let me just eat meat the right
data set
what I want to do is just take these
simple name so it's not too long
again let me just say that again and
then I leave the answer in here let me
rerun this
I have to do the same test
so fun to test you can also just delete
this row save it that's nest
oh yes and another thing that should be
mindful of is just using dashes so
[ __ ] this
okay
so as we're waiting let's just finalize
this so in terms of other methods that
you have and this is useful to know for
feature selection and also for
classification two other important
categories of methods that are available
or discriminant analysis which means
that I want to separate again in the
same way like random forest but using a
different method separate by using a
straight line between my groups of
samples and you have a number of
different types of discriminant analysis
and the final one that is more focused
on efficiency our support vector
machines why efficiency because when you
have a lot of data and a lot of noisy
data right that could be useful for
random forests it's not going to work
for a linear discriminatory analysis
because you have a lot of correlated
values within the data set but at some
point you get to a good precision in
your classification but you want to
generalize it and you want to make it
effective so that you actually see a new
sample come in and you can apply that
and trust the accuracy a good method to
do that is support vector machines
because it uses a trick to transform the
data called kernel basically transform
in a specific way that the numbers that
you deal with so that you can have a new
dimension where you can simply cut the
threshold between the two types or
several types of classes and it actually
uses distance to the edges of classes
which gives it a lot more precision
compared to some of these other methods
so that's just good to know
and you've got some of those things so
now let's talk about interpretation how
do we interpret this data that we got to
get a biologically meaningful
understanding so the first thing that we
obviously need to do
to translate the NSG to some normal
understandable gene name and gene
ontology etc so let's do that
the very simple procedure you take in
the IDS of genes that you want and then
you convert them to a gene symbol and
you can have the option to have gene
ontology probably you can do this using
David or some online database because
you need a database to convert and one
to the other so here let me just quickly
demonstrate how we will do that you can
go back under utilities and let us add
on your cell lines we have here the list
of those 15 genes that were selected
using random forests continue and here
under annotation we'll just use the
older a Khan sample database for all of
these in his genes and all you need to
say is where is the gene ID itself and
which college so it's in column one save
this
the other thing that you might want to
do and we'll take a look at the results
here in a second but I think it would be
good to just finalize what you can do
here is what's called gene enrichment
and for gene enrichment what you need is
the full change in the p-value so if you
did differential gene expression or
let's say you have T test results
writing have the column for the p-value
and a full change that could be either
log full change or it could be adjusted
for FDR which would be a pea adjusted
value or something like that so any
result from V SEC or a jar or manually
created you can then also use this gauge
analysis which is the gene set
enrichment analysis that will actually
give you the pathways and produce images
of those pathways that you can see up
and down regulated genes on them so to
do that let's just upload the results
from the SEC for example and here again
you have to practice and engage you have
B second to now in D SEC - it's
important to remember which column is
which because you have to say it here so
you're looking for you know the first is
going to be you know your ID of the gene
and then you have log to full change
which is 1 2 3 4 right
and then you've got the PD adjusted
value
okay so here are the callings so the
first one is the gene ID then you have
the log to full change and then you've
got the P for Justin value is so this is
one two three four five six gene IDs one
gene difference that would be log full
change this would be for and here for
your threshold this will this is used to
generate the images so if you want to
select you know only a few that were
mapped so this is a threshold for
pathways not for genes you can increase
it so you can do for example a 0.9
writing that will give you a lot of
flexibility on what will be considered
significance
okay so this is ok so unfortunately our
time ran out let's just take a look
before we finished at the results of
these two pipelines
didn't work again I got a look at my
table again and see what's wrong with
that one this was checked on the
invitation so here is the result from
invitation just what it looks like so
here you can see for each gene the
common name gene symbol and then you
have description of each gene and the
gene ontology to the multiple gene
ontology domains and since we don't have
time to look at output from gage I
included here the zip file and that is
the result from gage so if you unzip
that you will see the pathways and then
you can see based on full change what is
up and down regulated so the top you
also have here a text file which is
going to list out in the pathways so you
can see that the gene sets and pathways
and then you have the p-value and the Q
value and set sides so you will find
those images inside and so that's it I
hope that it wasn't too fast this time
if it was then I think the majority of
this stuff is online if you find
something that's missing online let us
know we'll update it or try and add
additional information you have any
technical issues you're welcome to reach
out to us and tell us this is the name
of the pipeline it's not working
we'll take a look and try to figure it
out thank you
if you have any questions
[Music]